every time i would go to the bathroom
it would be blood but honestly just
laying there would just be blood
chrissy teigen is keeping it real about
her pregnancy complications
and opening up about her hospitalization
i was always always
bleeding the 34 year old model got
candid on her instagram story on sunday
alerting fans that she spent the day and
evening in the hospital
after weeks of mandatory bed rest the
simplest of terms we can say my placenta
is really really weak
you know i'm about like halfway through
pregnancy
and um uh the blood
has been going on for like a month
so like maybe a little bit less than a
month but we're talking like
more than your period girls um
definitely not spotting a lot of people
spot and
it's usually fine um but
yeah mine was a lot today the big
difference was that
it kind of was like if you were to just
kind of
turn a faucet on to low and leave it
there
and just kind of leave it
but christy assured fans she's actually
feeling great
it's so weird because i feel really good
i feel like you know i'm usually at my
happiest pregnant i have
mood wise and i feel like
that way i feel happier than i do not
pregnant so that's why it's so
so hard for me to come to terms with and
the cookbook author said the baby boy
growing in her belly is healthy
and doing well the baby is so healthy
like growing stronger than luna or miles
um he moves a lot he's he moves like so
much earlier than
than they ever did he's like a roly-poly
and every we have like a million great
pictures of him
basically he like is the strongest
coolest dude
in the shittiest house so
his house is just like falling apart all
we're doing now
is trying to make sure that he's got a
lot of fluid around him
and so yeah it is scary um
but a scary in the way that there's just
really
nothing to do as for anyone on social
media
offering chrissy medical advice tips or
tricks
she's politely requesting you don't do
that
the most unhelpful thing is when
i get suggestions of you know from
medical
twitter and instagram like have you
tried this have you done this
because all it does is make me feel
really anxious and nervous
and like i did something wrong or so
just
well i know that sharing my story is
naturally going to come with people
trying to be helpful but um at this
point since i can't really do anything
and baby can't really do anything it's
not really that helpful
so please don't of course by chrissy's
side through it all her hubby john
legend
who even whipped up a custom chrissy
sandwich at her bedside
and there you have it thank you e.t
spoke with the voice coach in august
before the couple announced they were
expecting their third child together
john had this to say about the
possibility of expanding their family
we don't plan these things uh we haven't
planned them right now but uh
uh we'll see what happens we spend
enough time together
you never know